he can run every route you can dream up
I know I say that about other receivers
but he can run double moves he can run
by you he can run crossing routes he's
very good after the catch but what's the
greatest thing about this man as I've
told all our receivers if you get a
chance to watch him practice you'll see
what unlocked the greatness in him he's
the hardest-working man I think in
football hardest working player I've
ever seen practice and I've seen Jerry
Rice I've seen a lot of good ones but I
put an Tonio brown at the top that's Jon
Gruden from December talking about
Antonio Brown if he had said those
things last week a tampering case would
have been opened immediately and maybe
Chris if your conspiracy theory is Right
the tampering case should be open
because maybe this has been in the works
behind the scenes for weeks but the guy
with the perpetual scowl now is gonna be
coaching the guy with the perpetually
ear-to-ear smile how does Jon Gruden
take Antonio Brown and go X's and O's
here tell me how you okay what Antonia
brought me into that offense and get the
most out of it okay certainly I I mean I
think the the first thing in there is
Antonio Brown and what Jon Gruden said
about him at practice I wouldn't it be
for I've been there during two-a-days
and the training camp I mean Antonio
Brown before practice after practice
it's off the charts as far as drills
work ethic all of that stuff and I've
always heard that so that's amazing but
as far as the offense and how Jon Gruden
is going to indoctrinate him into the
Oakland Raiders football team in his
offense in general well the first thing
he's gonna do Mike I mean Mike is gonna
he's gonna show however how awesome a B
is to everybody on the football team I
know how Jon Gruden app operates he
likes these renegade type of players and
Antonio Brown he believes and having a
handful of them on his football team we
had him in Tampa Bay I know he welcomed
that he thinks it gives the team a
little bit of an edge but I think the
first thing he's going to do the first
team meeting they get in he's in the
show tape of Antonio Brown he's gonna
wax poetically about him he's in the
show film of these plays were showing
right here and go look what we just
brought to the team look at this guy
we're gonna be make him plays on he's
gonna get the team excited about Antonio
Brown he's gonna have
then buy it then from there when it goes
to offensive meanings he's in the start
showing some of his plays in his
playbook but on video run by guys like
Jerry Rice or sterling sharp back in the
day or Joey Galilei in Tampa Bay there
and gonna show some of the great
creative ways he's been able to focus
the offense around those type of
receivers and what they can do and he's
in a Blake 8 - Antonio go look these
guys are really good I think you're just
as good you're as good as I've ever seen
Antonio Brown he is going to make
Antonio Brown the first read on every
play in the pass game Mike and when I
say for those out there listening ago
what is the first read the major design
of the play is going to be for Antonio
Brown and Jon Gruden loves this so he's
gonna have it drop back he's gonna have
him coming in motion or move him around
all these different positions to where
yes you're the primary targets supposed
to get the ball and he is gonna wear
that out until teams start to go all
right that's enough
we'll take away Antonio Brown and that
of course is going to open up everything
for everybody else but he will ride that
card until taken away and I've seen him
do it before and I know he's got to be
ultra excited about having this guy on
his team but here's what I saw last year
I saw Amari Cooper on the Raiders who
wasn't getting the ball and I saw Jon
Gruden saying we got to get the ball to
Amari Cooper well Derek Carr is the guy
who's gonna be expected to make this
happen and look what occurred after the
Raiders traded Amari Cooper to the
Cowboys all of a sudden he's getting the
ball how much pressure does this put on
Derek Carr I think it puts a ton of heat
on him to make sure he does get the ball
to Antonio Brown cuz now he's gonna be
hearing that not just from Gruden he's
gonna be hearing it from an Tonio brown
as well ya know there's no doubt about
it I mean he's gonna feel pressure cuz
he's gonna want when you to like him and
he's gonna want to please him and throw
the ball correctly and make sure you
know that oh you know you're buying into
me is the quarterback - Antonio Brown so
I get that now I'm Ari Cooper that was
just over the relationship was over
there Amari Cooper you heard him say it
was like he changes a human being when
he went to the Dallas Cowboys but hey
they're gonna have to feed in Tonio
Brown it's a good problem to have I know
if I was a quarterback I certainly feel
a little pressure but I'd be glad I
throw the
ahem
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports